comme les infections nosocomiales.
Je maintiens que c'est en partie
un problème d'écologie de bâtiments.
Bon, je vais vous raconter une autre histoire sur cet immeuble.
Je collabore avec Charlie Brown.
Charlie est architecte,
et il est profondément préoccupé par le changement climatique mondial.
Il a consacré sa vie au design durable.
Quand on s'est rencontrés et qu'il s'est rendu compte qu'il lui serait possible
d'étudier de manière quantitative
l'influence de ses choix de conception
sur l'écologie et la biologie de la construction,
il s'est vraiment enthousiasmé, parce que ça ajoutait une dimension nouvelle à ce qu'il faisait.
Il a cessé de réfléchir uniquement à l'énergie
pour commencer à réfléchir à la santé humaine.
Il a contribué à la conception de certains des systèmes de traitement d'air
dans ce bâtiment et de la façon dont il était ventilé.
Alors, ce que je vous montre d'abord
c'est de l'air que nous avons échantillonné à l'extérieur du bâtiment.
Ce que vous regardez est une signature des communautés bactériennes
dans l'air extérieur, et comment elles varient dans le temps.
Maintenant je vais vous montrer ce qui s'est passé
lorsque nous avons manipulé expérimentalement les salles de classe.
Nous avons bloqué leurs circuits d'air toute la nuit
de sorte qu'elles ne puissent pas être ventilées.
De nombreux bâtiments sont administrés de cette manière,
probablement là où vous travaillez,